-Andy Cohen.
Andy, you are a huge producer,
but you're also a fan
of reality television,
so we thought we'd put
your knowledge to the test.
It's time for the
One Second Reality TV Quiz.
Here we go.
-♪ One Second Reality TV Quiz ♪
-All right.
Now, here's how it works.
We're going to play an iconic
moment from a reality TV show,
but it's going to be
just one second long.
-Okay.
-Okay?
Now, the first one of us
to hit our buzzer has to say
what show it is and what was
happening in that moment.
-Oh, God.
-If we're wrong, the other
person gets a chance to steal.
Are you ready for this?
-Yeah.
-I know, I know.
Look how nervous you are.
-I am, I am.
-Okay.
Let's see the first clip.
-[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Oh, come on!
-Teresa Giudice
flips the table!
"Real Housewives of New Jersey"!
-Yes. Exactly right.
I knew that one. Come on.
Ahh! That was honestly --
That was --
-It was very easy.
-I know, but that was not fair.
I knew it was probably
going to be in there somewhere.
That was the first one out.
-Right. Yeah, yeah.
-But that was Teresa.
Oh, my God. That was legendary.
-Legendary.
-The table flip.
She's in the new show,
"For Real."
-She is?
-Yeah, of course.
-She has to be.
-Yeah.
-That was one of the best
plot lines of all --
-Amazing.
-She was on the show
when she was "Ju-dee-chay."
-Yes.
-Yeah. That was a phase
she was going through.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
Khlo-ay Ju-dee-chay.
-All right.
Let's see the next clip.
[Bleep]
-Yes!
That is, um -- I'm going to call
him The Hammer, but it's not.
His name is The Situation.
That was "Jersey Shore."
And he got so mad at somebody
that he freaked out
and rammed his head into a wall
and passed out.
Remember that?
Let's roll the next clip.
-♪ When I was flying ♪
-Oh!
That's one of my favorite things
I've ever seen in my lifetime.
♪ When I was ♪
He's a songwriter
on "The Bachelorette."
And it was the Ali season.
-Wow!
-Ali Fedowsky?
-Good job. Yeah.
-Is it Ali Fedowsky?
-Something like that.
-What is it?
Does anyone remember
her last name?
-It was when Kasey serenaded Ali
on "The Bachelorette."
-Yeah. That's right. Kasey was
there, and he was a songwriter.
And she goes,
"If you're a songwriter,
why don't you sing me a song?"
And he goes...
[Sheepishly]
♪ When I first saw you ♪
[ Laughter ]
-Are you doing --
Is it Aaron Neville?
-Dude. Can we show that
one-second clip one more time?
'Cause it's one of my favorite
things I've ever seen.
-♪ When I was flying ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ When I was flying ♪
♪ Hmm, when I was flyin' ♪
Oh, I loved it, loved it.
All right. Here we go.
What is the score? Do we know?
-It's 2-1.
-Thank you.
-[ Laughter ]
-Let's roll the next clip.
-Oh, no!
-"Below Deck." And that was --
My buzzer didn't work, either.
-Just make the sound
with your --
It's our first show back.
-Okay. Well, I got it.
It was "Below Deck."
-Yes. "Below Deck."
-Yeah, and they're fighting
in the galley.
-Yeah, fighting in the -- Yeah.
'Cause someone slept
in the guest cabin.
-Right, right. Okay. 2-2.
-It is 2-2. All right.
Let's roll the next clip.
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Ah! Aah!
-That was "Dance Moms."
And that was tax evader
Abby Lee Miller screaming.
-That was -- Screaming.
-At a contestant.
-All right.
-Okay.
-All right. Abby Lee Miller.
Here we go.
This is the final round.
This one is worth 1,000 points.
-Okay. Wow! 1,000 points.
-So whoever wins this
wins the whole shebang.
-Okay.
-Man. All right. Here we go.
Gosh! Abby Lee Miller.
That was great.
And what was the name
of the villain,
the group that was against her?
Like, the Apple?
-Candy Apples.
-Candy Apples!
-The Candy Apples.
Oh, my God. Classic.
-I love that show. Oh, my gosh.
-Iconic.
-All right. Here we go.
Let's roll the clip.
-That's $75,000!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It works! Oh, my gosh!
-That was "Keeping Up
With the Kardashians,"
where Kim lost her ring
in the water.
There you go! That's it.
♪♪
Aren't you happy
you came on the show?
-No! So you won?
-No, but here's the deal.
You're the real winner, Andy,
because you look great
and I'm so happy you're here.
There you go. Andy Cohen.
"For Real:
The Story of Reality TV"
premiers Thursday, March 25th,
on E!